hello and welcome to world stories this
is your international reporters magazine
i'm sumi somaskanda we're going to take
you on a journey around the world from
haiti to egypt and bulgaria so buckle up
we hope you enjoy
we start out today in the haitian
capital port-au-prince the united
nations launched its mission in haiti
called minusta back in 2004. it involved
deploying peacekeeping forces to help
stabilize the country which was in the
midst of political upheaval that had
turned violent those troops also helped
recovery efforts in the aftermath of the
massive 2010 earthquake that devastated
haiti
in our next story untv sandra miller
introduces us to a man who found a
unique way to pay tribute to the blue
helmets as the peacekeeping troops are
known by carving their figures in wood
his project was an instant hit when he
started nine years ago and demand for
his wooden soldiers is still booming
today
every saturday the brazilian military
base of the un stabilization mission in
haiti or minusta is transformed into a
market
the hottest items here are these wooden
soldiers depending on size they sell
from 15 to two hundred us dollars
german manas is the creator
you can pass at 10 30 and you not find
anything anymore
when every one of the brazilian
militaries takes one soldier everything
is already sold
lieutenant colonel anuruda senevaratne
of menusta
today that i have ordered some u.n
soldiers three soldiers of course there
are some three but contingent commanders
are going out in the next week for them
to be presented from as uh memento from
the minister
these wooden figures are hand crafted in
downtown puerto pass near the busy kong
in manassas workshop each month between
120 and 150 soldiers are made here this
means regular income for many of these
craftsmen like sean samuel rosenberg
this activity helps me to live i can
also say this is a gift i got from my
father who is also a sculptor when i was
born i saw him working i have learned
from him how to work
manassas enterprise began in 2004 when
the un set up a mission in haiti at
first manas was making only little blue
helmets then a brazilian soldier asked
him to sculpt a soldier it took manas
one whole year to create and perfect the
design from there his business took off
now he's also producing boards with the
logo of the united nations often
accompanied by messages in spanish and
portuguese
every time the militaries are living in
haiti they are in a hurry they need
urine surges boards and thousands of
other things they put me in a position
to work quickly to split the wood cut it
in a form paint and vanish it
manas knows all the details of military
personnel
coloring the little soldiers is the last
step in the production
the varnish is barely dry the customers
have already arrived
as usual the clients are satisfied with
their small wooden soldiers that look
like them
sergeant roberto urizandi of the
guatemalan military
we decided to come to us for some
souvenirs for the people that are going
home
and also we normally ask
some souvenirs for the people that visit
us too
so he's a good working man that's why we
come here
manas is always ready for other commands
his shop opposite of the headquarters of
minusta has a strategic location for his
business
with the help of his team and constant
demand for these special soldiers these
craftsmen may live a life with economic
stability and hope
now we head to egypt for a story about
an up and coming entrepreneur ahmer
shadi came up with an idea to provide
service content to cell phone users and
he's turned that concept into a booming
business
his father is also a powerful
businessman an armor could have followed
in his footsteps but he decided to try
his hand at something new on his own
now armor has his set sight set high
he's planning to make his company a
global player emerging stars tv
correspondent raymond hussler harm sat
down with a young entrepreneur
yeah we want this to be a one billion
dollar company if we can and we will in
2020
you know what's wrong with having a
company from africa be the next facebook
or be the next google
egyptian businessman um shady has set
his sights high
he's the ceo and founder of ta telecom
a successful mobile services and app
provider
the company was founded in the year 2000
and has quickly grown to one of the
leading telecommunications companies in
the middle east
we met him at the headquarters of his
company in egypt's capital cairo
i mean we started really as a in a
bedroom with a with a credit card and
two people
working
in the company as in the very beginning
and then we
ended up
now we have maybe around 50 employees
generating around 4.5 million dollars in
annual annual sales
it's no surprise that amshadi became an
entrepreneur
his father owns a large international
engineering company and amsha was
expected by many to take the reins when
his father retired
i've been i can let me say i've been
groomed in a way that to be an
entrepreneur from early on because
um i was kind of uh being set on a path
to to
work in my father's company and sort of
take help in in my father's business and
maybe take it over
with time
but ams decided to buck expectations and
strike out on his own
he still remembers the day he had to
tell his father he would be starting his
own company
i i can almost remember that
conversation and his reaction and i was
very surprised that he was extremely
supportive
well i was happy that he has this uh
this
courage and this entrepreneurial spirit
because and to start
okay because
not to depend on me all the time because
he was sheltered he was protected he was
having everything in the company
but to start on his own
that needs a gut needs
confidence
needs a
belief that he will succeed
a lot of companies yes our family
family-owned businesses that are kind of
inherited from generation to generation
and lots of the successful companies are
like that
really the feeling of not i didn't want
to really let him down
um
it was just very obvious that i've i
have been that
i was supposed to be helping out i was
supposed to you know take the company
over when the time is right so you know
just kind of scratching these plans for
me was was the um
was the biggest burden that i had
you are from different generations and
yet you're both egyptian tell us what's
the big difference between the two of
you
tell from what you see
i see i work very hard
do you work too hard too hard
he's working hard
but his colleagues and his
uh
intel well his friends entrepreneur they
don't work that hard
but i still i me i might disagree
because we also work very hard maybe in
a different way but we work very hard as
well
so i mean my work day may it can start
at uh four or five in the morning and
keep on going until 11 or 12 at night so
try to learn to be a little bit more
lazy in terms of getting very good
people to do some key functions
and
having them learn from their own
mistakes
as long as they're not detrimental but
yeah in my work at this time there's no
room for mistakes for delay you have to
be on top of it so that's why i have to
make sure because otherwise it cost me a
lot
although he has a very busy schedule
amps still finds time to visit the
mosque five times a day
well really first it's it's really an
obligation on any practicing muslim so
it's something that we have to do
irrespective of how busy we are
that said we also i also see lots of
value in it um not just because it's
something that i have to do as an
obligation that you have to fulfill
towards god but more
um it allows you to really you know
think and see you know kind of
disconnect of this really hectic world
very busy world and uh you know really
understand you know what what are you
doing here
and what it what really is important for
you
so it's really a way for me also to to
continue the day
so business and religion are a bit
integrated is that what you're saying
definitely because religion also gives
you the ethics and the values of how to
conduct business how can you run your
company how to care for others how to
care for your customers how to care for
your employees how to have this you know
also the ethics towards your other
shareholders so it is very intertwined
in my opinion
ams is determined to grow ta telecom
even further into a billion dollar
global enterprise
in my opinion you really need to uh in
the very early stages of your your
startup you really need to
involve yourself a little bit more in in
the details and just understand the how
each function operates and how they
relate to each other and how
you know just
be very aware of the business inside out
so i like to say that there's no job
in this company today that i haven't
done i realized the importance that if
this company is going to grow even more
then i need to again focus on where my
strength is focus on the innovation part
a little bit more how can i have
innovation distributed across the
organization not centralized how can i
have more people do
more of the management the day-to-day et
cetera
good luck to amer and his business
now to a story about an unusual form of
cooperation in a small village tucked
away in the russian district of
sverdlovsk the saint nikolai church is
in desperate need of a makeover the
beautiful building is two centuries old
and much of saint nicolai's elegance has
faded its priest was searching for a way
to keep his church alive when he came
across an innovative idea to restore
saint nicolai by bringing drug addicts
on board and as rt's rania druidi tells
us the priest believes the project has
paved a path to salvation for the church
and the addicts
the saint nikolai church may look like
an ordinary place of worship but the 200
year old orthodox church has a surprise
in store
badly in need of restoration and is
turning to an unlikely source for help
former drug addicts are helping father
victor return the saint nicholai church
to its former glory
of course we needed a lot of money and
there was work to be done everywhere
but nothing was getting done for the
restoration
but then when the idea was suggested to
work with drug addicts to complete the
restoration
then i understood that saint nicolai was
waiting for it
the church's inspiring architecture and
the prayers and patience of father
victor offer the addict's refuge and
salvation from an unexpected source
it seems kind words mixed with prayers
and hard work is the right combination
to help these lost souls get over their
dependency on drugs
it's a different approach to fighting
addiction but instead of focusing on the
physical symptoms father victor's
approach focuses on the souls of the
afflicted and relies on their desire to
return to a normal life and here far
away from the temptation of the cities
addicts seem to have an easier time
rejecting drugs
the church is working for the
people that's why they're working longer
and harder on the restoration
and the people who are here helping
aren't just working physically
they also take part in church service
the work begins early each morning
restoration work and maintenance is
being done both inside and out they
started with the ceiling and walls of
the church but have since expanded to
mosaics and paintings participants in
the program are aware of the
responsibility that is connected with
their work but they're happy to have a
chance to contribute
i would say so
i'm happy to be able to stay here
we're working on the roof
it's an old roof
the paint has started to come off and
the ceiling needs support
the program was founded around three
years ago and currently includes
participants between 20 and 30 years old
in the last three years the project has
seen many successfully turn their lives
around as well as others who gave up and
left the saint nicolai church but
despite the setbacks program organizers
say as long as a single soul can be
saved then they'll continue with their
work
now we head to brazil where the landless
workers movement or mst has brought
together more than a million people to
fight for one main cause
comprehensive land reform the mst wants
to see deep-rooted inequities in land
distribution resolved and they believe
the only way to do so is to give poor
workers who have fled to cities access
to land back in the countryside in our
next story we visit one such project in
the state of minas gerais where families
are learning how to live off the land
they received but as raita minas tv's
carlos agusto suarez shows us experts
believe teaching them the right way to
cultivate that land is the key to
providing for future generations
i was born in rosa
and moved to belo horizonte
then i came here from there
i had nothing when i arrived now i have
my cows which i can milk
i have an old motorcycle that i can
drive around on too i have everything i
need you know
six years ago edson was one of the first
to arrive in the settlement of visconde
in minas gerais
originally a sugar factory stood on the
800 hectares of land
now around 30 families are making a life
for themselves on the property which was
confiscated as part of the land reform
i observed that the overwhelming
majority of the working class and
especially candidates for a spot in a
settlement like this
are extremely poor
these are very poor people coming from
high risk areas
what is the difference between urban and
rural poor is it better here
it's much better
it's easier here if you need money in
the city you have to go to the bank and
then to the market
here you can find dandelions sweet
potatoes and tapioca on your doorstep
here you reap what you sew
in so you don't go hungry
there's always something to eat
here in the settlement you die with a
full stomach
in brazil many dream of owning their own
property life in the country offers a
radical change from brazil's overcrowded
mega cities where there's little room
and growth is almost uncontrolled
for some getting back to nature offers
the best chance to improve their living
conditions
it's a new chapter of my life
i'm building something here that i'll
have for as long as i live
it's my future my baby
when i die i'll leave something behind
for my son
this land is everything for me
that was your dream right
exactly
now you have to learn how to cultivate
it yes
today in the 21st century it's almost
impossible to create a settlement for
people without land without giving the
farmers the proper resources
they need to work with the latest
technology
to keep up with the pace of change
and bring their methods in line with
proper environmental practices
we believe that sustainable or as we
call it in latin america agroecological
farming is an important tool
we want an agricultural industry that's
independent from chemical fertilizers
pesticides and herbicides
in other words an agricultural system
that produces food and protects the
environment the
also wants to help settlers build a
better community
our real goal is to help people create
the right foundation to develop their
land
and of course it should have an
agroecological focus
the production should help improve
conditions for the entire community
and not focus on competing on the market
our production principles focus on the
proper treatment of the planet
exchanging information and ideas is
critical for settlers hoping to survive
in the country just like learning to
plant crops on each of these small farms
students professors and farmers are
working together to make sure that the
land can once again support sustainable
agriculture
and finally we take a look at an
important anniversary and an effort to
honor war heroes it was 100 years ago
that the first balkan war broke out
between the ottoman empire and an
alliance of four countries one of which
was bulgaria
hundreds of thousands of bulgarian men
were called up to fight yet over the
last century many of their names and
their sacrifices have been forgotten
that's where the bulgarian state archive
comes in the agency is trying to restore
all of the fallen soldiers records and
make sure that bulgarians today honor
their service
the year is 1912 the place the bulgarian
capital of sofia onlookers are reading a
poster describing the mobilization for
the first balkan war the call is out for
fresh recruits in just a week's time the
bulgarian army would swell to 600 000
soldiers with more than 1 100 heavy
weapons
on september 29th the bulgarian army set
up camp in the town of stara zagora
under the command of king ferdinand
bulgaria started military operations on
october the fifth
eleven days later the first bulgarian
reconnaissance flight took place
pilot radu milkov accompanied by prado
anthrachev took off from sveilingrad
airport in an albatross f2 biplane
during their 50 minutes in the air over
the region of ordering they were able to
locate ottoman forces and attack an
important target a military camp on the
karaka river the conflict between the
ottoman empire and an alliance of
bulgarian serbian greek and montenegrin
forces ended one year later with a
victory for the allies
it's been 100 years since the first
balkan war ended
i still don't know the names of the real
heroes of that conflict
there is a monument in the center of
sofia dedicated to the unknown soldiers
but it only demonstrates our lack of
knowledge
in the 1930s the ministry of war started
to prepare a complete and detailed list
of all the dead bulgarian heroes of the
balkan wars
the list fills more than 30 volumes and
took over a year to digitize
here in front of us we can see one of
the books of names which we digitalized
in it we can find a wealth of
information
not only about the fallen soldiers but
also where they perished and their final
resting places
this will allow there some 250 000
descendants to find the graves of their
great grandfathers with just a few mouse
clicks
if they want they can pay their respects
by lighting a candle or laying a wreath
in this way we hope to restore their
interrupted family histories
the bulgarian state archive hopes the
information will draw attention to the
soldiers who served in the war
bulgarian
unfortunately in bulgaria
many family histories were interrupted
for decades
some families only know their own
history back to the start of the war
i think that's why our national holidays
are only seen as days off work rather
than celebrations of national pride
the melody of whistling marissa paid
tribute to the battles of the balkan war
this is my family memory from the first
balkan war
which was passed from generation to
generation
the goal of our project to digitalize
and upload the names of more than 48 000
people who died in that war is to help
bulgarian families restore their family
history and re-experience these
historical events as a part of their
family's story
and with that we've come to the end of
this edition of world stories from all
of us here and our partner stations
around the world thanks for watching
don't forget to watch this show again
head to our website at d w dot d e world
stories we'll leave you with this week's
picks of the world see you next time
bye
you